you know how when you hear that
something costs government 800 billion
dollars it can be kind of hard to really
make that number practical it's such a
big number hard to make coherent sort of
practical sense of it and the same is
true for the number of lies the Donald
Trump has told over 928 days in office
which was as of August 5th about a week
ago Donald Trump has told 12,000 19 lies
this is the latest tally from the
Washington Post's analysis this is about
13 lives per day over the entire
presidency now as we've become
accustomed to the Washington Post
doesn't want to call them lies they call
them false or misleading claims and I've
talked a little bit about the possible
legal repercussions of actually using
the word lie but they are lies and
Donald Trump lately is lying even more
the average for the presidency is 13
lies per day but since April of this
year it's been 20 lies per day as I
mentioned earlier the lies are often
about immigration they've also been
about the economy about trade about
Russia and I do agree that this is a
problem Donald Trump either can't or
won't tell the truth but for me the real
issue is the sort of quality and
outrageous and audacious nature of the
lies rather than just the quantity of
Lies the quantity is shocking but Donald
Trump has basically skated free from his
lies and a big reason for that is that
his followers will rationalize the lies
away with something like oh all
politicians lie but they believe that
even though Donald Trump lies just like
any other politician Trump has the right
ideas and he's doing the right things
and it leads to zero accountability no
impact no effect no consequences now I
want to believe that independent and
centrist voters do care about the lying
and that therefore when we finally have
a Democratic nominee the Democratic
nominee needs to be equipped to call
Trump out on the lies during the general
election debates or the Democratic
nominee is simply going to have no
chance I know that we've talked about
cognitive decline and that's a good
conversation to have about Trump but
there's
actually a much more obvious condition a
personality disorder narcissistic
personality disorder and this may make
it difficult for the eventual Democratic
nominee to really effectively call Trump
out on his lies first let's just look at
the criteria for a narcissistic
personality disorder which requires at
least five of the following nine a
grandiose sense of self-importance
that's absolutely something Trump has a
preoccupation with fantasies of
unlimited success power brilliance
beauty or ideal love Trump certainly has
that a belief that he or she is special
and unique and can only be understood by
or should associate with other special
or high status people or institutions
100% the need for excessive admiration
obviously I mean it's almost like
describing Trump a sense of entitlement
of course interpersonally exploitative
behavior yes a lack of empathy
obviously envy of others or a belief
that others are envious of him or her
110 percent a demonstration of arrogant
and haughty behaviors or attitudes Trump
hits nine out of nine and only five of
these are required criteria for a
diagnosis of narcissistic personality
disorder so this is what we have it's
pretty clear Trump his entire life has
been of the mindset that he just needs
to say whatever will get him through the
next 30 seconds and it'll all get
cleaned up later
usually by somebody else so I think that
the idea of just having a Democratic
nominee that will call Trump out about
his lies during the debates is not going
to be as much of an easy win as some
people might imagine Trump is good at
one thing which is surviving the next 30
seconds and if Donald Trump can survive
the next 30 seconds and then the thirty
seconds after that and then the thirty
seconds after that during the debate
that may be enough to keep him from
losing his supporters his core
supporters because he's able to just
save face and get out of the debate when
you're president the lies are a major
problem for the economy they're a major
problem for our relationships with other
countries but Donald Trump's approach is
going to continue to be the same and it
is one of surviving the next
thirty Seconds say whatever you can to
get through the next minute and then
deal with the repercussions on the back
end often with even more lies so this is
something that is going to be an issue
during the debates I think it's going to
be more difficult than some might
imagine for the Democratic candidate to
actually hurt Trump with and speaking of
the general election debates will any
network hosting the general debates have
the testicular fortitude for lack of a
better term to call out Trump every time
that he lies and call out the Democratic
candidate for lies as well by all means
but will they have the bravado and the
strength to face the critiques that they
have it in for Trump so to speak or will
they simply call out that is not true
mr. president what you just said is
untrue it's an easy moral decision for
me but I can bet you that the network's
are going to find it a much more
difficult decision to make and they
probably will not call out Donald
Trump's lies during the general election
debates let me know what you think make
sure you are following the David Pakman
show on twitch at twitch TV slash David
Pakman I will be streaming this evening
at 6:30 p.m. Eastern Time and I hope
you'll join me there